ce n'est pas le rassemblement espérer
des grands jours ce matin quand les
enseignants arrivent au compte gouttes
au total ils sont 150 du calvados et de
la manche pour dénoncer leurs conditions
de travail
on a plus de formation continue en tant
qu'enseignant alors qu'on est on est les
plus mal lotis l'art c'est nous qui
sommes dans le système éducatif
on a plus de formation continu sur le
temps de travail du touch depuis cinq
six ans
et puis les salaires aussi faim les
on a un salaire qui baissent de fait
parce que l'on a dit ce n'est pas
revalorisé problème de formation
salaires et surtout classes surchargées
les ont poussés dans la rue dès la
rentrée prochaine dans l'académie vingt
neuf postes devraient être supprimés
dans le premier degré et dix autres dans
le second degré avec la baisse du nombre
d'élèves
ça fait des années que les enseignantes
les enseignants se battent pour avoir
moins d'élèves par classe il ya un
rapport qui vient de tomber qui dit que
ça a un impact extrêmement important sur
les conditions de la réussite des élèves
donc nous aurions dû conserver nos
postes pour pouvoir travailler dans de
meilleures conditions
le collège s'est rendu au rectorat où
une délégation a été reçue
c'est dans les collèges que la grève a
été la plus suivie aujourd'hui en région
avec un taux de 8 et demi pour cent à 11
heures selon le rectorat